Well, good morning. What a tremendous grace and gift it is to have such talented, gifted
worship leaders that truly lead us in worship. So thank you, worship team. This morning,
we're going to be in Psalm 13, so if you would, open your Bibles and read with me.
How long, oh Lord, will you forget me forever? How long will you hide your face from me? How
long must I take counsel in my soul and have sorrow in my heart all the day? How long shall
my enemy be exalted over me? Consider and answer me, oh Lord my God. Light up my eyes
lest I sleep the sleep of death, lest my enemies say I have prevailed over him. Lest my foes rejoice
because I am shaken, but I have trusted in your steadfast love. My heart shall rejoice in your
salvation. I will sing to the Lord because he has dealt bountifully with me. This is the word of
the Lord. Would you join me in praying? Father God, open the eyes of our hearts that we may behold
wondrous, glorious, gospel-centered truths from your law. Move this sinful, broken vessel out
of the way and speak to us. In Jesus' name and for your glory we pray. Amen. So how are you this
morning? Really, how are you? It's the awkward pause. Not just the Sunday answer, but the real
answer. As if we're sitting down for coffee and you fully trust me. How are you? How is your soul?
I was involved in campus ministry and college and we had all these retreats, summer retreats,
winter conferences and at each one there invariably was an older, more seasoned believer that would
get up and kind of share their story. They would talk about their testimony, their story,
and it always started with these stories of struggle, heartache, struggle, sin, and I found
myself saying, yes, I can relate to that. Yes, I'm so glad they're sharing this, but then
they always pivoted to the, but then I came to know the Lord and it was as if everything was
fine. And I found I could not relate to that part. I related to the struggle, but I'd never
related to the sense of perfection after coming to know Christ. It was almost too much like
the facing the giants movie where after that pivotal prayer, I mean the job is restored,
the marriage is restored, the high school football team wins, they're dealing with
infertility and suddenly they're pregnant and life is just glorious. And that does happen sometimes,
but I think for most of us and at least for me, the experience is that's not the Christian life.
I couldn't relate to that. And in our text this morning, we see an incredible picture of despair
and trust. It paints a very real picture of the anguish we really can feel in our lives
and souls, yet it paints an even better picture of what a life of deep faith really looks like.
This Psalm is classified as an individual or a personal lament and I'm so thankful for Tom a few
weeks ago who really kind of led us through teaching, you know, the different types of laments,
but this one is a more personal lament versus a communal lament that's representative of a whole
group. And that's one of the reasons why I love this Psalm because it's as if we've been given the
privilege of opening up and reading David's private prayer journal. It's an intimate look at how he
struggles, how he wrestles and what he does about it. And the other thing I love is it's
not clear to us what's going on with David as this is written as we do in other Psalms. For
example, you know, when David's fleeing from Absalom or after David committed adultery with Bathsheba.
Now in this one we know there's a struggle but we don't really know why. And I love that because
it prevents us from saying, well, yeah, I mean, of course David's dealing with this, but I've never
fled for my life. Or yeah, of course he has these experiences and emotions, but I've never
committed adultery. This Psalm, however, is one that we can lay over, lay on top of any circumstance or
situation in our life and directly apply it. And so it's six verses. I've broken it up into three
sections. I was super excited to do this part because I've preached a handful of sermons
and I've never been able to do this, but I was able to hearken back to my
Southern Baptist upbringing and we've got three points and they all start with ours.
So we're going to look at this through the lens of David's reality, David's request, and David's
rescue. So what is the reality? What's going on with David? Look again at verses one and two.
How long, oh Lord, will you forget me forever? How long will you hide your face from me?
How long must I take counsel in my soul and have sorrow in my heart all the day?
How long shall my enemy be exalted over me? In these first two verses we hear that question,
how long, four times, which absolutely highlights the intensity of the felt emotions.
David feels forgotten by God. And notice he doesn't ask, God, have you forgotten me?
He feels it so strongly that this is a foregone conclusion.
David has forgotten, I mean, God has forgotten David to the point he wonders and asks,
will you forget me forever? He takes it a step further, again, feeling so deeply that he knows
God has hidden his face from him. And the face of God, his countenance,
that was a symbol of God's presence, his favor, his blessing. We see that in numbers with Aaron's
blessing. The Lord make his face shine upon you. The Lord lift up his countenance upon you
and give you peace. So what David's saying, what he's praying is that God has removed
these things from him. He's withdrawn from David, alienated him, left him alone, put him on a shelf.
Can you relate to that? Have you begged God to intervene in a situation and felt unheard,
maybe even forgotten? I've been there. I've felt the distance. I've wondered, what did I do wrong?
Or what have I not done right? And at times I still hear those voices from youth camp years ago.
If your life isn't right with God, you might just miss your chance. And he might put you on a shelf.
It's almost as if I've got one shot, one chance to make it or blow it. Or in the words of the great
theologian M&M, you only get one shot. Do not miss your chance to blow. This opportunity comes once
in a lifetime. Otherwise, God will put you on a shelf. God will hide from you. I know I lost
some of you all with that. Others you now have lose yourself, run around in your mind. You can thank
me later. But those feelings and emotions, they're real. And David goes on to show us how deeply
this is affecting him. That idea of taking counsel in his soul and having sorrow in his
heart. The Hebrew words there point directly to worry and anxiety that leads to agony and grief.
You feel it so deeply. You're sick to your stomach. It's a very real form of deep depression.
And he's basically asking God, am I going to have to deal with these anxious and fearful
thoughts alone for the rest of my days, day and night? He's alone. He feels abandoned.
He's full of anxiety. And he feels like the enemy is just wiping him out.
And what enemy is exalting over him? He talks about the enemy exalting over him.
What enemy? Is it the world? Concerns, circumstances, a person? Life in general?
Is it his flesh like a sickness or a disease, a temptation, a sin? Or is it the devil,
the tempter, the liar, the thief, the destroyer? Again, the beauty of the Psalm is we don't know
exactly what, but I would argue it's yes. It's likely a combination of all of those
that's affecting David. Again, can you relate to that? That distance defined my felt experience
for many years. And again, that's why I love the first part of all those testimonies I heard.
I could relate to the struggle. And I also remember feeling like I had been put on the shelf,
like I'd blown it too much or too often. And I had to take counsel in my soul alone to figure it
out. That's David's reality. That's what's going on with him. But what did he do about it?
Look at David's request, verses three and four.
Consider and answer me, oh Lord my God. Light up my eyes lest I sleep the sleep of death,
lest my enemies say I have prevailed over him, lest my foes rejoice because I am shaken.
What does David do? He prays. He prays specifically. He ties his prayers back to his reality.
David felt forgotten by God, so David asked God to consider, to look at. That the Hebrew
word actually means to look at, to behold. In fact, it's the same word used when God told Abraham
to look into the heavens and count the stars. It's not a mere noticing or a passing glance.
David is asking God to look intently at him and to fully absorb every detail of what's going on with
him. And he asked the Lord to light up his eyes. This reminds me of our journey through Ephesians,
having the eyes of your heart enlightened that you may know what is the hope to which
he has called you. Or in Psalm 119, open my eyes that I may behold wondrous things out of your law.
Psalm 19, the commandment of the Lord is pure, enlightening the eyes. David's request, his
prayer shows us where his hope is found. He doesn't pray for the situation to end.
He prays for God's presence, his gaze, his intent looking at him. And he prays that his eyes would
be enlightened to see what God wants him to see through this. And we absolutely have to notice
the names God used to address God, the names David used to address God in these verses.
Because that shows us the level of his faith and why he can so boldly request God's help.
He called upon the Lord, Jehovah, the God with whom he has a covenant relationship,
the God who is faithful to keep his covenant. And then he goes on to say, Lord my God,
the Lord was his God, Elohim, the strong, the powerful one. Only God was mighty enough to help him.
Only God could deliver him. David confessed through these names that he had a covenant right
to the resources of the Almighty One. David is acknowledging his utter dependence on the
Lord, his King, his sovereign God. And at the same time, acknowledging his own weakness,
as he goes on to say, because I am shaken. It's good and right for us to pray the promises of God.
To point back to what God has said in his Word and expect him to keep those promises.
Like Hebrews 4.16, let us then with confidence draw near to the throne of grace that we may receive
mercy and find grace to help in time of need. Or Jeremiah 29.13, you will seek me and find me
when you seek me with all your heart. Or Deuteronomy 31.6, be strong and courageous.
Do not fear or be in dread of them, for it is the Lord your God who goes with you.
He will not leave you or forsake you. Those are the promises we have to point back to.
Those are the ones that we have to say, God, you said this, keep your promise to me.
And I said it earlier, this is such a beautiful picture of a life of deep faith.
Because in these four verses, we already see David's progressive trust in the Lord his God.
At each stage, David could have, as we so often are probably prone to do,
he could have gone his own way. After the reality part, when he pours out everything,
his heart to God, he could have then wallowed in self-pity and self-indulgence
to maybe medicate or distract away from those feelings. But he didn't. He took it to the Lord in
raw, brutal honesty. And then the request part, absent immediate circumstantial relief,
he could have taken matters into his own hands to try to solve whatever's going on,
to try to manipulate or control his circumstances. But he didn't. He took it to the Lord
with a request of what he truly needed, God's presence, his gaze, his blessing,
not the immediate circumstantial relief. And there's absolutely nothing wrong. And we should pray for
circumstantial relief. We should pray for healing. We should pray regarding our circumstances. We
should pray for what we believe we need. But our anchor, our hope, our primary request,
the thing that will really matter and make a difference should be God's presence.
And that's why this next part is so pivotal. This is David's rescue.
But I have trusted in your steadfast love. My heart shall rejoice in your salvation.
I will sing to the Lord because he dealt bountifully with me.
We've seen David's brutal and raw honesty and his feeling of abandonment by God.
We've seen his calling to God for help, for his presence, for his rescue.
And now we see where David's hope is anchored. We absolutely have to notice that his hope is
not anchored. He doesn't mention that his issues have been resolved. Nowhere in here do we see this.
It's not anchored in that circumstantial relief. David is rescued because of his trust in God's
steadfast love, his covenantal, unbreakable love that is tied to his own nature, his own name,
his character. And that's what marks a life of deep faith. Not simple happiness only when
everything's worked out, but true joy in God's salvation.
Singing not solely because of the circumstantial relief, like when we get the good news phone
call from the doctor or we get the new job, but because of the goodness of God in our lives,
regardless of the circumstances. This is David in the midst of his fear, his pain, anxiety,
rereading his prayer journal and being reminded of the steadfast love and goodness of God.
He's looking back at all the ebony's or stones in his life, those markers of God's goodness and
faithfulness, and that causes him to sing. What are some of those markers in your life?
Where can you look back and marvel at the goodness of God? We have to remember those.
We have to be able to recall them. It's like the author of Lamentations in chapter 3.
We see 20 verses of deep suffering and grief all the way to the point in verse 18. He says,
my endurance has perished, so has my hope from the Lord. It's perished.
But just like David, he doesn't terminate with the pain, the loss, the hopelessness. He goes on to proclaim.
But this I call to mind. And therefore I have hope. The steadfast love of the Lord never
ceases. His mercies never come to an end. They are new every morning. Great is your faithfulness.
So how do we get to that type of deep faith?
First, we have to be brutally honest with ourselves and with the Lord.
Call it like it is. What's going on in your soul?
Second, we have to seek the Lord's face. Ask Him to keep His promises. Ask Him to open the eyes of our heart.
And finally, we need our but God moment. Despite my circumstances, my pain, my struggle,
I trust in the steadfast love of God, His never-ceasing, unbreakable love for me,
right here and right now. Recognizing we don't always get the why.
We don't always get the answers we want, but we trust in the goodness of God and we rejoice.
That doesn't happen overnight. That comes from a life built around abiding in Christ,
day in and day out. And we cannot do it by ourselves. There's going to be times when
you're not strong enough to pray or to believe like David or to even remember the goodness of
God. And that's the beauty and grace of community. When we're not strong enough to
remember or believe or even pray, our brothers and sisters join with us in that.
And that's why home groups, which Brandon mentioned, are so pivotal. You've got to have that. You've
got to have those folks lifting up your arms, lifting you up in faith. So if you haven't
had an opportunity to visit one, I implore you, try it out. We meet midweek. We pray together.
We do life together and we look at Scripture together. And speaking of a life of worship,
last week, Jennifer and I were listening to a worship devotional by a group called
the Worship Initiative. It's this daily devotional they put out. And the lady
leading the devotional said this, and I loved it. Worship is, I love you,
God because of, in spite of, and in the midst of whatever circumstances.
20 years ago this summer, my older brother, three years older than me, my best friend,
died suddenly. I got that phone call that no one is ever prepared to receive.
And I remember talking to an older friend about it. I had a whole bunch of whys.
It didn't make sense. I saw there was no way there was good in that. And I honestly question
the goodness of God. And my friend told me, sometimes you have to have this little file
in the back of your mind that just says, God, this doesn't make sense. And you got to be comfortable
putting things in that file without the answer. And that helped. But now, 20 years later, after 20
more years of ups and downs and huge mess ups and buckets of grace and mercy, I would change that.
I still have the file that says, God, this doesn't make sense.
But that file lives in an infinitely bigger file. This got the title of Psalm 11968,
talking about God. You are good and you do good. Period. He's good and he does good.
And he does good. And I will trust in his steadfast love for me. That's what cultivates a life of deep
faith. So as we wrap up, I think one of the greatest lessons we can take away from our journey
through the Psalms this summer is it's acceptable and good and right to pour out our hearts to God
in raw and brutal honesty about what's really going on with us. Not that Sunday morning.
How you doing? Oh man, I'm blessed. Brother, how are you? Oh, I'm blessed. Not that version,
but the grimy, the raw version to lay it at Jesus' feet. We see in Scripture and we often
talk about the fact that David is referred to a man after God's own heart. That's not because
David had it all together. That's because David knew where to go amidst not having it all together.
So for the believers in the room this morning, this is good news. The Lord your God,
the sovereign one is calling you right now to give it to him. To give it all to him.
You don't have to figure it out. You don't have to try to fix it.
And for those maybe that haven't fully trusted in the Lord yet, the good news is the same God who
created the heavens and the earth knows you by name. He knows your struggle. He knows the pain
and he's calling you to simply surrender now to his loving care just as you are.
You don't have to clean yourself up to come to him. So if the worship team would begin to make
their way back up, I asked you all at the beginning, how are you? So really, how are you?
Who are you trusting in? What are you doing with the pain, the anxiety, the frustration,
and the unknown? As the team begins to play, I'm going to ask you to join me in praying through
a slightly edited version of our text. And I'm going to ask that you truly join me,
that you don't just listen to me. I'll pray a few phrases to guide us and then I'm going to
pause and ask that you pray quietly to yourself. Tell the Lord what's on your heart. Take it to him.
He wants to hear from you. So let's pray.
Lord God, how long will I have to deal with this? How long until I have the answer or receive relief?
How long will I have to wrestle with these anxious, controlling thoughts and feelings all alone?
How long will this temptation, these lies, this grief, plague me?
Look intently at me and my situation. Oh Lord, my sovereign God,
enlighten the eyes of my heart to know your hope and your mercy. Keep your promises to me
because I am weak and needy.
But this is what I remember and this is why I have hope. Your steadfast love, oh Lord, never ceases.
Your mercies never come to an end. They are brand new every morning, God. Your faithfulness is so great.
And so now I rejoice in the fact that while I was still your enemy, far from you, a rebel,
you, Jesus, came to die for my salvation. Because of your great love for me, just as I am,
not a future cleaned up, more put together version of me. Not because of my goodness,
but because of yours.
And now I'm going to sing
because all my life you've been faithful. All my life you've been so good.